avoir un premier indice pour cette
personne s'il vous plaît en régie tic je
me qui snj hop tu adores premiers
indices en régie la france c'est
quelqu'un qui a participé en acceptant
est ce que vous avez je pense qu'ils
n'étaient pas habillés en vert
abstinente un nom alors tu confonds avec
théo le lavabo
deuxième indice chaud le 20 juin la
valise 21 le jour de la fête des pères
après le 21 juin sous crois que c'est la
fête de la musique vous avez plusieurs
tubes à votre à votre compteur way est
juste là pour le merci sophy est-ce que
ça a un rapport avec une saucisse
0 rien à voir la chipolata ces
derniers lundi s'il vous plaît en régie
jeux 3d 3d au tgp donc vous êtes
chanteur en fait j'arrive pas à
comprendre
en plein dans le mille c'est un chanteur
d'être ce que vous vous appelez daddy
des bonnes réponses de delphine wespiser
au riad idée est avec nous sur le
plateau de
âge alors david et ont déjà découvert en
2011 dans la france a un incroyable
talent on garde ça passe vite votre
prestation tu connais
non j'aime en laine
en ces pourcentages
passe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
tha
[Musique]
david et c'était en 2011 la france a un
incroyable talent vanessa a été un
tremplin pour vous cette émission ah oui
beaucoup et
j'ai fait beaucoup de choses avec c'est
grâce à cette émission ouais vous êtes
devenu très célèbre non pour aller
parler beaucoup dans tpm paie d'ailleurs
est ce que vous connaissiez décidé je me
suis souvenu armoyan nam évoqué quelque
chose et vous avez continué après à
faire de la scène ben
quand on a commencé tôt
on a du mal à prêt à se détacher de ce
qu'on aime profondément depuis toujours
fait ça la scène et vous êtes dans la
coiffure maintenant
je pourrais peut-être à l'occasion
c'est pas du tout aimé chanter monsieur
projet aujourd'hui je suis non
vous êtes je suis mon genre et bonjour
ça n'a aucun rapport avec ce que je
viens de dire si vous êtes bon genre et
donc du tout genre il faut vous appeler
monsieur c'est ce qu'on me dit souvent
d'arrêter des dites
vous disent que vous voulez vous quand
ils vous appellent alors si vous aimez
les ailes à dire qu'on m'appelle
hockey et vos projets c'est quoi alors
aux journaux bien sûr présente alors une
dizaine d'années on vous avoue partout
sur les plateaux télé à presstalis ou
mais je crois vous avez une petite
traversée du désert un an après ah oui
appliqué pour mais vous savez c'est bien
ouais parce que c'est vrai que quand on
voit quelqu'un à la télé qui commencent
à devenir précédemment crois que c'est
quelqu'un qui gagne énormément d'argent
qui travaille déjà pour vous donner
c'est la merde ça fait
relativiser
je ne fais pas de
cette célébrité une fin en soi j'ai bien
vécu j'ai manger à ma faim j'ai voyagé
je continue encore un peu a voyagé avec
ce titre avec ça vous allez voyager oui
et d'ailleurs je vais continuer de
voyager encore avec cette jolie chanson
l'année prochaine et c'est vrai que ça
mais bon ça bertrand ouais bien sûr mais
c'est très sympa ça avait cartonné
vous allez faire d'autres tubes des très
bonnes ans et voilà et justement on va
se quitter puisque c'est déjà la fin de
vidéo gag on va se réveiller en musique
l'idée si elle va alors justement oui je
prépare un nouveau titre qui s'appelle
d'ailleurs paradis d'accord sur le 15
décembre et pour lequel un spectacle
sera donc monté autour du paradis show
avec donc des artistes de différents
univers
du delà de la chanson du spectacle et
aussi des spectacles un ibiza rodez
livrions très bien belle idée en live
sur le plateau de vidéo gag merci à tous
d'être avec nous en direct sur ces
mythes et aristide renversé à moussa et
deborah pour l'émission merci bien
évidemment des aléas cyril hanouna on
retrouve dès demain en direct
à l'évidence est là
[Applaudissements]
voir des deux invités
au marché en
ils moi qui mois
[Musique]
fida
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]